same storm system battered the Northeast
overnight with snow ice and rain that
means dangerous travel conditions for
millions of people in this area this
morning snowfall is heavy in many areas
from Pennsylvania through New England
airlines have canceled more than 500
flights in this storm
will be followed by a dangerous deep
freeze DeMarco Morgan is in Boston where
the winter storm warning is still in
effect and DeMarcos right in the middle
of all of that DeMarco a good morning to
you good morning to you Gale as well the
schools are out today and downtown it's
pretty quiet as it would be considering
a day like this would have we snowfall
as you can see right here behind me but
just take a look at this it's pretty
picturesque but again traffic is moving
slowly people are still trying to make
their way through here some who had no
choice but to go to work out today but
the winter weather advisories are still
in place for parts of New England so you
definitely want to keep that in mind
also they have any snow is responsible
for blanketing on the roadways here it's
the biggest snowstorm Boston has seen
all season snowfall totals have reached
more than 15 inches here this winter new
jersey is under a state of emergency and
more than 2500 plows and spreaders have
been deployed to clear heavy snow in
that state making roadways nearly
impassable for drivers the storm began
in the Midwest over the weekend bringing
heavy snow and high winds and icy
conditions caused car crashes across the
region the storm isn't the end of the
winter misery you talked about a gale an
arctic air mass is bringing wind chill
warnings and advisories that will spread
into the plains to the east through
Wednesday back to you all right tomorrow
thank you